s
♪ ♪ ♪
- À première vue,
rien ne distingue
quelle autre joaillerie
à Toronto. La différence,
c'est qu'ici, la plupart
des diamants vendus
sont équitables ou canadiens,
ce qui veut dire qu'ils
répondent à certaines normes
environnementales et
socioéconomiques. Et bien que
la Russie soit le plus importa
producteur de diamants au monde,
vous ne trouverez pas ici
de diamants russes. Une offr
qui plaît de plus en plus
à la clientèle, surtout depuis
le début de la guerre
en Ukraine.
KESHA FRANK, DG et cheffe de la
odododuction Fair Trade Jewelley
- Il y a certainement
des clients qui viennent
nous voir qusosososososososososs
avoir des diamants de Russie."
Avec la guerre, ça a aidé
les gens à réaliser que
connectés à la politique et que
c'est très important de savoir
où nos matériaux viennent.- Ave%
des exportations mondiales,
la Russie est le plus important
fournisseur de diamants-t-t-t-té
de sa production vient du géant
minier Alrnenenene entreprise
détenue en partie parrererereres
àààà la vente de diamants
ont totalisé plus de 4 milliards
de dollars en 2021.
(coup de feu)
Depuis le début de la guerre
enadadadadadadadadadadadadadadÉs
ont annoncé des sanctionsvevevet
Sergueï Ivanov. Et certains
des plus grands bijoutiers
du monde comme & & & & & Co.
et Pandora se sont engagés
russes. Une situation
qui pourrait avantager
le Canada, troisième producteur
au m
sont considérés ieieieieieurs
comme plus responsables.
se spécialise dans la vente
de diamants canadiens depuis
près de 15 ans s'attend
de la demande pour les diamants
canadiens au cours des
prochaines années. Il ajoute que
le Canada s'est doté d'outils
comme le code de conduite
sur les diamants canadiens
pour garantir l'authenticité
de ces diamants et leur
permettre de se démarquer
sur le marché. Cet expert
souligne toutefois que
les diamantsnénénénénénéficient
toujours d'importants débouchés,
puisque des pays comme l'Inde
et la Chine n'ont pas imposé
de sanction contre la
Les diamants canadiens peuvent
coûter de 10 % à 15 % plus chers
que les autres diamants
sur le marché, notamment
en raison des coûts liés
aux mesures de traçabilité
pour garantir leur origine.
On conseille donc aux
consommateurs soucieux de
l'origine de leurs diamantsdedes
directement à leur bijoutier.
Ici Andréane Williams